[Music]
too
[Music]
hi and welcome to the vlog this is going
to be a very weird different one but i
do mention here and there that i do kind
of like cbt with myself and i do like
self therapy here and there when i can
and i get a lot of questions on what i
do specifically and what are the
exercises that i do and how i reset
myself to show you exactly what i do to
kind of reset myself
when i need it so let's get started
let's get chatting shall we let's talk
about cbt um this is really cool i'm
excited about this by the way i'm not a
mental health professional so i don't
know how to describe this it's just
something that i've tried again and
again but i'm definitely not an expert
in but basically cbt is a form of kind
of therapy i think it's a combination of
talking therapy but it's a very active
and proactive form of dealing with your
issues and your problems and basically
it's part of you know all of the things
that we try to do in therapy to try to
help someone feel better and the reason
that i particularly like cbt is that you
don't necessarily need a therapist to do
it um at least of course like i wish i
had a therapist all the time but um
that's just not feasibly possible
because it's quite expensive and it's
kind of difficult to access or get
online having therapy in the past i've
taken my cbt exercises and they're
things that i do um by myself all the
time so they're tend to be very very
helpful for me so um yeah it's just a
kind of an empowering way of viewing
your life and viewing your world so the
kind of exercises and ways of thinking
and frameworks that i used in cbt are
during therapy themselves are things
that i use by myself again and again
and basically how it works is i'm sure
there's various different ways i'm just
going to discuss not even the things
that i particularly did in therapy
because i don't remember all of them but
i'm going to discuss the ones that i'm
going to be doing today and the things
that i kind of do whenever i tend to
kind of feel like i'm spiraling or not
feeling too well um so they tend to be
basically exercises and frameworks to
approach anything happening in my life
and how i organize that into something
that is more effective a better way of
viewing it perhaps and in a way that
will change my thoughts will change my
behaviors and will change my approach to
things and will hopefully mean that i
have a better experience overall
so i think the first thing that i wanted
to address is when do you know that you
need therapy or when do you know that
you need kind of help or when do i know
for example that i need to take time out
and at least for me the times there is
two times one is when it's blatantly
obvious and that's either when i feel
extremely low for a long amount of time
or if i'm crying a lot or if i'm just
feeling
just having a really bad experience in
general i'm sure everyone knows what
this feels like when you just feel bad
when you feel like saying that you're
depressed even though that's kind of
technically a diagnosis but when you
feel like saying i'm depressed i'm low
and i'm unhappy um i think those are the
cases when i know that okay we need to
intervene here because things are not
okay but the other time is sometimes i
feel and this is a new one for me
because i didn't realize that this was a
problem before if that makes sense um
and that is when i have
kind of unreasonable reactions to things
that are happening in my life so what i
mean is for example if there is a
situation or if i am having a
conversation with someone someone or if
something happens to me and i have an
overreaction and it doesn't need to be
an extreme reaction because i'm not
someone who tends to get very angry for
example so it doesn't have to be like
that but if even in my internal states i
feel extremely low or extremely
triggered or extremely vulnerable or
extremely scared or um kind of extremely
insecure if something happens in my life
that is a small action but triggers a
huge reaction by proportion in me i
realize that i'm carrying something that
has not been dealt with and i'm bringing
something else to the conversation
so what i mean for example is that let's
say someone said um hey elizabeth we are
i'm going to cancel our dinner tomorrow
um if a friend of mine said that and my
reaction was to start crying and or my
reaction was to feel as though um feel
extremely sad and feel abandoned and
feel as though this friend doesn't like
me and um they must hate me therefore or
they must not want to be friends with me
any longer or i'm just not funny i'm not
interesting these are thoughts that i've
had in the past when an action like this
has happened and these i think we can
all agree are out of proportion to the
action itself the action of someone
canceling dinner could mean simply that
they just didn't have time or they had
to rearrange something or they just
didn't feel like engaging with someone
else and if i'm taking that person me
and kind of feeling really really
abandoned and feeling really miserable
and feeling horrible it probably means
that i'm carrying things from my past
and bringing these other assumptions to
the table entering these assumptions of
my own into the conversation and the
interaction that are leading to a
terrible experience on my part which is
just not there and i think that's when i
realize when i have outer proportion
reactions
um that
i probably have issues that i haven't
dealt with and i think it's quite good
that once in a while i tend to do this
as often as i can i kind of
reevaluate what assumptions i carry in
life because by doing that i think i i
get to kind of deal with my issues as
they're arising rather than let them
accumulate and i think it's completely
impossible to be like 26 years old and
to not have issues it's just not
possible things happen in life um and if
we're not dealing with them kind of
constantly if we're not doing some
spring cleaning and i like to use the
word mental hygiene because this is what
i call it i quite like in my mind it's
mental hygiene it's you have routines
around cleaning your body i do have
routines about cleaning my mind too and
making sure that one i address issues
that are really really deep seated and
those i tend to do with a therapist so
um when i had very and i still
have i don't think you ever get rid of
them fully but i had deep seated issues
from my childhood and those are things
that i have addressed in therapy and
potentially will still dress in therapy
in the future um so those are kind of
the
ingrained problems in my life and then
as i go forward in life um things will
happen all the time there will be micro
um
kind of conversations or micro
rejections or micro failures or kind of
micro angers and micro hurts that i'm
just accumulating every single day and
they are potentially subconsciously
building this narrative in my mind that
can be not so good um and these
narratives can be grandiose can be like
i'm an incredible person um i don't
deserve the things that are happening to
me or these narratives can be very
negative in the sense of um you know i'm
unworthy this is why these things are
happening to me
mine tend to be on the negative end of
the spectrum um which means that my
default state tends to be that of quite
low self-esteem um and i tend to blame
myself for a lot of things that are
happening in the world and in my life um
which is not necessarily true and i know
that i carry assumptions in my mind or
at least i have carried assumptions in
my mind in the past that i am kind of
not a very
good person or i'm not a very clever
person i'm not a very beautiful person
i'm not a very funny person i'm not a
very interesting person and um therefore
i don't deserve good things and
i think that there's i'm going into this
long round sorry this is going to be a
long video you know what i'm just gonna
put this video out the way that it ends
up being so um i've taken this time out
to kind of reevaluate where different
things stand in my life and see
why i'm behaving and why i'm feeling the
way that i am and what kind of
underlying assumptions do i have behind
that so that's what's going to happen i
don't know why my food is not here yet
so i'm really keen on getting the food
here as soon as possible and then we're
going to do the exercise yeah let's do
that soon i'll try to put together a
notion template too just in case you
want to download it that way so it makes
a bit more sense but i'm going to go
through the logical
flow of what i do when i try to
kind of lower my anxiety and do self-cbt
and kind of organize my thoughts on what
i'm thinking so let's go through it
together okay let's start the first
thing that i do is i create a long list
of things that i'm thinking about at the
moment
and this is kind of like a brain dump
and i write literally everything it's a
combination of anything that's on my
mind it can be something that i haven't
done yet a to-do list or something
really really bored like a common
anxiety i've been having over the last
few days or anything that i've been
thinking or pondering or like stressing
over um
so everything basically goes down here
one thing that i like to use as a prompt
for this
and this is not awful but i like to
think of the things that make me feel as
though being punched in the gut like
what are the things that just make me
feel like oh this if you've ever had
anxiety or dread or something like that
or if you've ever been like overworked
you're like really really stressed with
things that you're doing you know that
feeling
it just comes from your guts as there's
something that's being like
wretched out of you and or punched into
you so those are the sort of things that
i use as a prompt like what in the last
month or the last few months having me
has been making me feel as though i'm
being punched in the gut and i will just
write down the list of this whole thing
and once i have this like complete brain
done what i will do is then turn it into
two categories so on one side on one
list i'm going to put the things that
are
tasks so a to-do list sort of situation
and on the other side i'm going to put
things that are kind of like to process
so i create a to-do list and a
two-process last not to do list go
things like if i have um kind of
deadlines or stresses over work if i
have things that i need to kind of
organize if i have things that i need to
think about like things like this
youtube channel my podcast my job my
course my other job the videos i need to
film for work and
the slides i need to prepare and the
things that i need to do and organize
and um going back to university and
organizing university having to move
house all of these things will go into
my to-do list because they're literal
actions that i need to do
and so then everything that is left
becomes a true process list and this
means it's kind of like a
something that has to more of an effect
or some way that i feel and an effect of
something that i've been going through
or something that's happened to me
recently that will go into my two
process list now whether to do this this
tends to be the easier thing to do
because um i can i will structure things
with order of importance because
sometimes um they there's just too much
and
there's so many exercises that say just
write down all the lists of the things
that you want to focus on and then just
pick three and delete all the rest i
cannot afford to do that unfortunately
so i will try to leave this to three or
four things and then i'll say for
example i'm not going to continue my
podcast for a while or i'm not going to
do my course for a while or i'm not
going to do this aspect of my job for a
while um because i just can't
do all this right now so this tends to
be the list of things that i can
either leave for later or say that are
the top or the top list of importance or
the bottom list of importance or
anything in between so that will be my
to-do lesson that's sorted not too
interesting the most interesting thing
is the two process list and this tends
to be all of my beliefs all of my
anxieties all of my worries all of my uh
kind of concerns or the things that i
potentially want to say or do or haven't
done or just things that are brewing in
my mind and kind of just all the
awfulness that creates that low-key
anxiety or kind of like depressive
feeling inside me so this will go into
my two process list and i will just
write all these things down together and
then i will group them and they will go
into categories depending on kind of
what they are talking about so is this a
body image issue is this a self-esteem
issue is this a
um i don't want to go into detail on to
what mine are but it tends to be things
in these sort of categories for example
love category family category friendship
category loneliness category um kind of
worthiness category so i tend to group
these depending on what the kind of
belief is if that makes sense so they
tend to fall into themes and once i have
these themes this time around i had five
themes
i want to have five different themes and
these are just one word so it can be
like love or it can be a person or it
can be
a belief or it can be just a
like a a topic in general these tend to
be five things and then what i will do
is i will start my theory a theory b now
theory a therapy is something that um my
therapist taught me like two years ago
and it was really really helpful at the
time and i still use it now for so many
different things not for what it was
originally used for on me um and
basically what theory a theory b is
theory a is the belief that you are
function the assumption that you are
functioning under and this is super
important because
um theory a
it really gets down to the core of what
are the assumptions with which you are
living if i say that consciously i
believe that i deserve happiness right
this is something that i believe however
if i see that i am consciously doing
things or not doing things in order to
self-sabotage myself and in a way kind
of make myself not be happy and
if i keep doing this consistently it
means that actually i'm functioning
under the true assumption that i am not
worthy and i don't deserve happiness and
that is the core belief so that's very a
and even theory a tends to be like a
very extreme stance but it's the one
that
even though you wouldn't want to say out
loud and once you say you know it's
ridiculous you actually believe it
because that's the theory with which
you're functioning so if um i have core
beliefs the theory a's of like i am
extremely ugly or if i say what i feel
people will abandon me or i don't
deserve
things that i have in life or
so it can be very extreme stances
on this so with all of these five themes
that i had the five problems that i have
i will put my theory a and theory a is
based on my actions over the last few
months based on my reactions to things
based on the things that i've done and
the things that i haven't done based on
the ways that i have felt
what do i actually believe about myself
and this will go in my theory a column
and this tends to be awful awful stuff
it tends to be really really terrible
stuff and i will just go into detail
that if this happens that happens these
are what are my beliefs about myself or
my core beliefs that i am subconsciously
functioning under
and then
after i've done this i will go into part
two of this which is what is my evidence
for this so what is my evidence for
example that i am unworthy and this can
be the fact that someone has said this
to me in the past um this can be the
fact that multiple people may have
sentenced to me in the past this can be
the fact that i have interpreted
something happening to me in life to
mean that i am unworthy um this can be
the fact that i
i believe that if um i do this thing
then people will abandon me so this will
be all the evidence that i can find in
my life that affirms this belief and i
will leave this there
then i'll go on to theory b so theory b
is okay we said that we're unworthy for
example what is an alternative
explanation here so theory b tends to be
the more realistic down to earth
reasonable explanation
so something along the lines of you know
we all have good and bad in us and we
all deserve happiness for example this
is super vague it doesn't tend to be
things like this i just don't want to
open up specifically about what mine are
but it will be something along these
lines where i'll go into detail that if
um people are all worthy or something
along the lines of
if you are honest and open with people
they will not abandon you or if you
express your needs in the long term it
means that people will stick around the
right people will stick around or if you
express your needs or if you express
your needs explicitly in the long term
it will mean that
the right people will stick around and
it will be this kind of theory b kind of
thing which is counter to theory a and
more realistic and then this is the fun
part i will go into my life to look for
evidence for theory b and this is
something that naturally i would never
do because i'm very much um
i like i find it a lot easier to find
evidence for negative things then i find
evidence for positive things but if i
try and this is why i love this exercise
because it gives me the space to go okay
let's consider for a moment that i'm not
the worst person on earth what is the
evidence for this and then i can go oh
you know my friend said that i was a
wonderful person last week or um i i'm
possibly not stupid because i got this
promotion at work or i actually did very
well in my exam and um it's highly
unlikely that i'm going to
completely fail and everything is going
to be a disaster because i have this
proof so it tends to be realistic things
in my life that affirm theory b
so once i have this balance of theory a
this is the assumption under which i'm
functioning which is really really
horrible and i admit that i have this
evidence that i've gathered from my life
that makes it true but what if
this theory be
so the opposite of this or something
more neutral was true and actually i
have a lot of evidence for this too and
because theory b tends to be very very
rational its evidence tends to be a lot
longer and a lot more reasonable so when
i look at things this way i can go
actually i think i've been i'm being
ridiculous and obviously theory a is not
true um there are some theory a's that i
have still not let go of even after
years and years of doing this exercise i
have some core beliefs that um are just
so difficult and i i do this exercise
again and again for them and you know
sometimes for a second i feel as though
i've just let go of this terrible thing
but then no it's it's not true but
anyways um so
i will see that theory is kind of true
and then that will lead me to my action
plan and the action plan tends to be
what sort of things can i do now so how
can i change my behavior in such a way
that reflects that theory b is true so
that could be for example
if i think i'm completely unworthy on
one end and that is because um two
people have abandoned me and a third
person has told me that i'm completely
unworthy and this is why i have this
core belief um on the other hand i have
to believe that i am not unworthy
because i have these other friends who
have said this other things and i've
done i've got what i deserve for xyz and
everyone is good and bad so there's no
there's no reason to think that i am
more unworthy than the average person
so once i have this theory a theory b in
the bottom of this i will then put kind
of um
what are my action points from there so
my action points from this might be
things like let me see what i've done
for my um my actual case here
i can be decisions um it can be
decisions based on behavior so it can be
okay um i no longer need to interact
with this person or i can interact with
this other person in a different way um
or
i need to make explicit my needs in the
situation or it can be actions or things
that i can take and it kind of gives me
the confidence and the space to do the
right thing basically that i would
recommend to someone else um because
it's a lot easier to believe these
terrible things about myself and it is
to believe them about other people so
i'm done with this i will basically have
these kind of
um
i will have these kind of
tables so i have a table here i have the
theme at the top i have theory a theory
b and then everything in theory a all
the proof of theory a everything in
theory b or the proof theory b and um
the evidence in the end and then it kind
of helps me i guess neutralize a lot of
these negative thoughts and get to the
point of being a bit more reasonable
about them
once i'm done with this it kind of helps
things but it doesn't let go of all my
anxiety then i go back to say saying um
what are the things that make me feel as
though i'm being punched in the guts and
i really like this question i use it
again and it kind of resurfaces either
the things that i have already dealt
with or new things that are just giving
me anxiety that are small things and
then i'll think okay um is there any
need here that is not being met so i do
like to do a needs less too and it needs
less goes through the things that i
the things that i need at the moment to
make myself feel better and it's kind of
like sitting myself down and explicitly
saying okay what do you need right now
and sometimes i have a need to be less
lonely
um so that means a need for love or a
need for affection or a need for
space a need for peace a need for time
off a need for
doing things that i enjoy um so i'll put
the list of my needs and then i will put
a list of the needs that have to do with
other people that i haven't expressed
because this tends to be quite long for
me i find it really difficult to
verbally express my needs which i think
is one of my biggest issues um so at the
end of this exercise i have an action
plan of people that i need to express
needs to and people with whom i need to
be a bit more explicit in my life and so
that's also done
and then um in the end of in the end of
it i will do two other nests i'm sorry i
just love my list and i love structuring
things like this i love breaking down
kind of the mess into very concrete
things um and at the end of this thing i
will do the
bad things that have happened to me
since i've done this exercise and also
good things that have happened to me
since i've done this exercise
and i do this because for the bad things
i can kind of look back on them and go
what kind of wrong conclusions can i
come to based on this event so let's say
i was rejected over something
will i have internalized than the
thought that i'm not worthy or will i
have internalized the thought that i
don't deserve good things or will i then
have internalized the thought that i am
ugly or stupid or um unlikable or
unlovable and i will kind of check that
conclusion so i will write that
conclusion down
and then i'll have the list of these
negative beliefs and some of them will
be the same as my theory a's there'll be
negative things that i dealt with
already but then i just kind of
resurface them and go okay i realize
that i've gathered evidence for these
terrible things over the last few months
can we just acknowledge now that this
isn't true and on the other hand and and
on the other end uh this is the part
that kind of takes me the most time is
going through the positive things that
have happened through the last month for
the last few months because um
generally i have such a negative bias
when it comes to events in my life um
and so
i find it sometimes difficult to
remember the good things but i since
i've been doing this exercise i've
become much better at this so i'll go
through positive things that have
happened kind of it might be a promotion
it might be something nice that a friend
said to me um it might be something um a
situation where i felt really good or
something that just made me feel great
about myself and i will write these down
and then i will see
these will usually fit into some theory
bees so give me evidence um to the
contrary of the negative things that i
tend to think about myself so yeah um
after that
basically i will then um look at all of
my action points together and i will
create one master list of action points
which i already have now um and this
will be a combination of my action
points for the activities that i wanted
to sort out an action point for
the
moving myself from functioning under
theory a and doing all these horrible
toxic not productive things to moving
more towards theory b which is more a
more neutral a more
objective a more not self-hating version
of elizabeth so then i will kind of um
work through that and yeah and send that
so then i will kind of work through that
um list of things to do and it kind of
gives me the structure of my mind i have
an action plan and i know what i'm going
to do and then um that is almost
everything the last thing that i do is
write a list of things that make me
happy um the things that i do to make me
happy so for example exercise especially
when i go to the gym and i'm on a
quality sheen this tends to be a very
happy activity for me i'm going to the
movies with my friends or watching a
movie with a friend um having good food
having meeting people
meeting new people um kind of creating
new connections especially when i meet
someone for the first time it tends to
be really really nice um
when i meet um
when i meet very old friends or when i
meet new people for very first time that
tends to be really really nice um kind
of stretching i just love stretching
it's such a good it just puts me such a
good mindset and i haven't done it for
like almost two three weeks now which is
completely bizarre um and
yeah i've and
creating videos that i do creating
videos and content i do enjoy um
listening to podcasts um especially
listening to podcasts while i'm going on
a long walk i haven't done this
basically since i was last in finland so
a very long time ago um
and
uh reading books especially non-fiction
so i've been reading um virginia wolf's
book this kind of get away and it's been
just so amazing so reading more books
like that reading more philosophy um
rereading books which i love to do and
sometimes i don't like myself because i
feel like it's unproductive so um i'm
really this this month i've just been
allowing myself to reread old books
again and again and it feels amazing um
and kind of
being like honest and being around
people that i enjoy and especially
touching
people die that i love i feel that i
love my joy i just love like cuddling
and physical touch just makes me feel
really really great so this is kind of
the list of things that make me feel
good and i think refreshing this in my
mind and going okay i want to do more of
this will make me feel better
so yes uh and also i've decided to
potentially take some more time off and
um structure my and have a bit more
boundaries around how i spend my time
and especially when it comes to work not
going always like yeah sure i'll do that
yes i'll do that at any time of the day
um any day of the week but rather
creating some more boundaries around
potentially having one day off
a week um would be great but
yes so that was basically everything
so yes that was basically everything i
am um going to wrap this video up here
potentially i don't know if i'll have a
bit of footage maybe tomorrow um but
yeah this was it this this has felt
great i really enjoyed not being
in my bed at home because i spent way
too much time there especially with the
um kind of the recent few weeks just
i've basically been in bed mostly um and
i was really sick of my room so um it's
great that i that i had this break
somewhere else and i feel really really
privileged and great for being able to
actually do this at all so yeah if you
made it so far honestly thanks
this is a very very random video um so i
hope it was helpful at all and i hope it
clarified a bit um what i tend to do and
how i do cbt on myself basically to try
to change my core beliefs and which is
basically what this is is
functioning under beliefs
that
are potentially not true and that i'm
not even realizing that i'm doing so
yeah um that was everything sorry for
the audio on this video because i don't
have a microphone with me i forgot it so
i'm recording on my camera which i never
do um so the audio might be atrocious
otherwise thank you so much for spending
this time with me as always i'm gonna go
and take a nice long bath and um yeah
and go home tomorrow
i hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day and good luck let me know how this
goes if you do try it out and if it
helps at all please go to therapy if you
can if you can get therapy and if you
can't afford it just do it it's the best
thing on earth it's been one of the most
life-changing things for me and i could
not recommend it anymore so yeah hope
you have a wonderful rest of your day be
kind to yourself and others and don't
believe everything you think thanks bye